Okay.
Support for the impeachment and removal of
Donald Trump has exploded and support for
the impeachment inquiry has nearly tripled
even among Republicans over the last couple
of weeks.
This is not good news for Donald Trump.
Donald Trump has been touting these cartoonishly
high approval ratings from Republicans sometimes
will tweet Republican 95% support.
Thank you and maybe that's true in some poll.
I mean I haven't seen it.
Maybe RAs mucin has Trump at 95% approval
among Republicans.
That's not the data that I've been seeing.
Most of the polls I've looked at have Trump's
Republican approval somewhere between the
high seventies and around 80 and what that
means is that there are one out of five Republicans
that do not approve of the job that Donald
Trump is doing.
This gets us to more specifically assessing
support for the impeachment of the president.
In the first week, that week between the start
of the Ukraine fiasco going public and a few
days after the impeachment inquiry was announced,
support for impeaching and removing Trump
went from 36% to 43% that was an increase
of about 20% another week has gone by and
support has increased even more.
The questions in this latest data are a little
bit different, but most importantly, support
for the impeachment inquiry has exploded among
all Democrats, Republicans and independents,
and it is growing in parallel across party
lines.
This is very important and it's important
because Donald Trump needs that Republican
electorate to win reelection in 2020 so first
49% in a Washington post Shar school poll
want the house to call for the removal of
Donald Trump.
49% of Americans, 58% of Americans say that
the impeachment inquiry is correct, that it
is the right thing to do, but maybe the single
most notable number to come out of this new
poll is that the move towards impeachment
has happened across party lines.
Democratic support for the inquiry is up 25
points.
Independent support for the inquiry is up
20 points and Republican support for the inquiry
is up 21 points.
30% of Republicans now support the impeachment
inquiry that Democrats are trying to carry
out, but does this matter, right?
I mean, why do we care in the end if three
out of 10 Republicans support the inquiry
because the Republican Senate is very unlikely
to vote to convict.
The reason we care is that the whole point
of this is to get people not to vote for Trump
in 2020 and I'm using very precise language
there.
Now I know that there are some people in my
audience holding out hope that the impeachment
inquiry could lead to Donald Trump's removal
because Republicans in the Senate will vote
to convict.
I see it as incredibly unlikely, but anything
is possible.
The much more realistic outcome is that the
success of the impeachment inquiry depends
on influencing public opinion.
When we look at public opinion, you see that
in two weeks, in two weeks, Republican support
for the impeachment inquiry has effectively
tripled from around 10% 1112 maybe it was
two 30% this does not bode well for Donald
Trump.
Now, a reasonably skeptical observer of this
would ask the question, if you're a Republican
and you support the inquiry, does that mean
you're going to vote for a Democrat in November
of 2020 and that's a very good question to
ask.
And the answer is, of course not.
You are not necessarily or even likely to
vote for a Democrat in November of 2020 if
you are a Republican who merely thinks that
the inquiry is warranted, but you might stay
home and that alone could be good enough to
pull Trump out of the white house, assuming
that we on the left get our base out as well.
In the last two weeks, we've seen Republican
impeachment inquiry support triple.
We have seen triple three, we've seen prominent
Republicans start to turn on Trump.
We've seen Looney, Lindsey Graham and Moscow,
Mitch McConnell, albeit not over the Ukraine
stuff, but over the serious stuff start to
sort of part ways with Donald Trump.
To some degree, we are seeing the right wing
media like Fox news embroiled in what I described
earlier this week or last week as an internal
cannibalistic battle over whether or not they
will be on the Trump train in 2020 and meanwhile,
Trump has gone out after according Ukraine
in a private phone call and courted the Chinese
for political dirt on Joe Biden after the
impeachment inquiry was launched.
Just imagine when you look at what has taken
place over the last two weeks, just imagine
what could happen between today and the next
democratic debate, which is in a week, uh,
unprecedented circumstances.
Donald Trump drawing a line in the sand saying
he will not participate in the impeachment
inquiry, whose support has now tripled, tripled
among Republicans.
Stunning stuff.
I want to hear from you.
What do you think is going to be the next
shoe to drop?
Make sure you are commenting.
If you're watching on YouTube, make sure to
send me a tweet on Twitter at D Pacman and
while you're there follow the [inaudible]
David Pakman show on Twitter at David Pakman
show.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this